Jocko.
There is an army cliche that I'm sure
you've heard of or you've heard that goes,
everyone's leadership style is different.
I've heard it used many times as a coverup
for a failed mission or with someone
who just isn't getting it done.
What's your opinion on this for
all the advice that you give?
There seems to be a continuous method to
your madness and some basic principles
for being a good leader.
Does everyone have a different leadership
style or is there an optimal optimal
method with personality tweaks?
That's just amazing how well this
Jujitsu comparison to this is, this is,
this is just an incredible translation
and if you know the way broad broadly you
you've seen in all things because what
this question is is exactly the same as
the question above and
the fact of the matter is,
if you know Jujitsu,
Brazilian Jujitsu, yeah.
You know the fundamental principles of it,
you can do these tweaks them. If you don't
know the fundamental principles of it,
you're just going to get destroyed now.
Okay.
If you're a catch wrestler that those
have the same sort of fundamental things
going on. You know what I mean? If
you know sambal. So if you know judo,
so I'm saying if you understand,
I don't know what to call them,
but if you understand like the fundamental
principles of submission grappling of
any kind,
if you know what those are,
then you can make some tweaks to them.
You can make some,
some adjustments to them to bait based
on your style and your body type and your
personality and your
strengths and weaknesses. Yes,
it is the same thing with leadership.
So people are going to
have different styles.
They're going to have
different styles of leadership.
Some people are super
caring, charismatic, right?
And that person could take
advantage of their, their charisma.
Some people like connect with other
people really easily. Some people don't.
You're going to have just different little
nuances to your personality and your
brain that are going to,
that you're gonna make a little
adaptations and your leadership style.
That's okay.
Where it gets not okay is if you
leave the fundamental principles.
That's where you have a problem with.
Because there was a,
there's an example that I thought
of when I read this question.
There was a guy that was coming through
my training when I was running the uh,
the advanced training for the seals and
he was making actually leafs told story.
You remember life, he's told the
story. I think it's in the book too.
I don't remember, but it's, it's podcast
book. We've talked about it a bunch.
We talk about it when we
to go talk to clients.
Life tells the story about how he was
trying to give commands over the radio and
no one's doing anything because it's
ineffective to give commands in the radio.
You know, when there's a lot of machine
gun fire and all the stuff going on.
So I said a life use verbal commands and
he kinda like looked at me like I was
crazy and I said to him and just
give it a try. He did it. It worked.
A couple of years later,
I'm running training.
There's a guy that's given a bunch of
commands on the radio and I go to him,
I go, hey man, use verbal commands. And
he's like, he's like, what do you mean?
And I'm like, yell at everyone so they
know what it is you want them to do.
They can't hear you on the radio. There's
a lot of stuff going on. And he goes,
I don't lead that way.
That's what he said to me.
And you know,
they just got destroyed because you know,
in his, I don't know if he thought like,
hey look,
I'm not going to yet.
I wasn't telling him to yell at US
people I was telling him like yelled the
verbal commands and he wouldn't do it.
And they just got
annihilated all the time.
And he ended up not doing well as a
leader because he was breaking the
fundamental principles of combat
leadership, like simple, clear,
concise commands that everyone understands
that if they don't understand it,
whose fault that is it,
it's yours.
And if you're talking on the
radio giving these complex orders,
people aren't going to understand what
to do. But if you give them the, the,
the standard operating procedure,
maneuver, command peel, right,
that's going to get passed
and everyone's going to do it.
So he strayed away from the
fundamental principles. It's like,
it's like saying, well, you
know with me, if I give you,
if I use a pressure point on your
neck, then I'll win. It's like, no,
actually that's not going to
be effective. You know, you,
the pressure point thing is a
fantasy. Oh No, it's real. Oh, okay.
It is real. You know what? And there's,
there's certain parts of your body that
hurt a little bit more when you press
into him.
I understand that that doesn't change you
from getting choked doesn't change you
from getting double leg take down.
You try and hit some of the pressure point
while they're doing a double leg take
down on you. You're not going to make
it. No, it was not going to happen. So,
um, you, you,
you have enough told this story too
about the guy that wasn't very loud and I
told them like, Hey,
you've got to get louder.
And eventually he got the guys that were
allowed in his platoon to start giving
the verbal commands cause he wasn't
loud enough to do it and that was an
effective way.
Still using the same principle,
just using a little bit of a different
technique. That's fine. So yes,
different leaders are
going to lead differently,
but the principles are going to remain
the same that the principles of ownership
cover, move, simple,
prioritize and execute decentralized
command and balancing the dichotomies.
And then there's plenty of them in
leadership. The good leaders out there,
they will follow those principles and
they'll make little tweaks to them based
on their personality.
And that's fine.
But a tweak doesn't require an excuse
and also effective or ineffective.
Like if you make a change,
if you do something a certain
way and it's not effective,
then whatever you change, this
isn't working. It's not working.
So use the fundamental principles, make
little APP to adaptations. It's okay.
But if a leader is ineffective
and they're failing, guess what?
Their little adaptations like,
hey, I could make up a new move,
right for Jujitsu and I,
and I call it the the
Wizbang. Sure. And I say, Hey,
I made up the school move. It's called
the Wizbang and let me show it to you.
And so I show it to you and you're like,
well,
I don't know if that'll work or not.
And I like, no, it'll definitely work.
The cool thing about Jujitsu is when I try
it, we find out if it works. Right now,
something doesn't work immediately,
right.
But let's say I keep drilling it on you
and drilling it on you and I can never
get you in the Wiz.
Okay.
And then I go on a tournament and I
try the Whiz Bang and I get smashed and
defeated, and then I go through
the constellation bracket.
I tried the Wizbang and it
gets smashed and defeated.
Then I go on the next tournament.
I try the Wizbang here,
you get smashed and defeated.
Then I get in the constellation bracket.
I tried the Wizbang and get smashed and
defeated and I do this for six months
and the whizzbang never works
effective or ineffective currently.
In effect, it's ineffective,
it's ineffective.
If you're in a leadership position or
someone's in a leadership position and
they're failing and they're failing to
execute the mission over and over and
over again,
they're little tweak that,
a little leadership thing that
they think is good to go. It's not,
it's not good to go. And it
probably, in fact, I'll tell you,
it violates one of the fundamental
principles of combat leadership.
And if you can identify which one
of those things it's violating,
you can get them to
clean it up and fix it.
So there you go. Whizz Bang. Don't
try it. Don't try the Wizbang.
I don't know though. I mean
these digits, Jujitsu moves.
You know how like guys like bus
up moves, man, I don't know. It's,
it's this endless thing to
notice. New moves come out. Yeah,
and you won't hit a move 100% of the
time and you definitely won't hit it when
you first started doing it.
It's going to be hard.
How many arm locks do you think you put
on someone before you made someone tap?
In the beginning you probably did 50
arm locks before you got someone to tap.
Yeah, probably more. Yeah.
Yeah. Maybe even more.
So that doesn't mean what the after the
first 49 outs and effective emoc going
to do it.
The big differences,
the big differences on arm lock is a
proven known entity covering move is a
proven known entity.
Simple is a proven known entity.
Prioritize. Next. Cute. Is
it proven known entity? Yeah.
Extreme ownership is a proven, known
and decentralized command is a proven,
it's like an art markets.
I could choke and that's why
when some people say to me, Oh,
well my boss doesn't
like extreme ownership,
you know, I know what's happening.
Like it's, they're the bosses.
Ego is offended because
there's some other,
some somebody telling them a
different way to lead. No. It's like,
what do you believe in? I don't believe
in extreme ownership. Oh, I blame him.
I believe in placing the blame on
other people. That's how I lead.
That's complete. Completely ridiculous.
Everybody knows that's ridiculous.
It's completely ridiculous. Cover move.
I don't believe in cover move. Oh,
so you just like your other team members
to go and take care of themselves and
you take care of yourself. How does
that work? It doesn't work. Keep the,
oh I don't like to keep things simple.
No, I like to make things so complicated.
Complicated that people don't
understand what I'm talking about.
Does that make any sense whatsoever? No,
it doesn't. Yeah. Prioritize and execute.
No, don't do that. What I,
what I'm going to do is spread myself
so thin that I don't have the assets or
resources to actually accomplish anything.
That's what I'm going to do.
Because that makes sense.
Cause I don't believe in extreme ownership
or those are the fundamental laws of
combat leadership. That's where
you're at. Decentralized Command. Oh,
I don't believe in that.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm going to make
every single decision myself from the
headquarters position.
When you guys want to make a decision out
there on the battlefield are out there
on the,
on the manufacturing floor,
I want you to run every single
division decision up through me.
Cause that's going to be effective.
So if you violate one of these principles,
you're going to have problems as a leader.
If you tweak these principles,
that's fine. If you look at decentralized
command and you're like, you know what?
I know that the normal kind of
span of control is five people.
I can handle more than that. I can
handle nine and you step it up. That's,
that's tweak. That's okay.
Right? That's fine. If you pray,
when you prioritize and execute, Hey,
oh the way I prioritize and execute,
and this is the truth.
The way I prioritize and execute isn't,
I look at my number one problem
and I only focused on that one.
I assign somebody to my number
one problem and I say, hey bill,
go handle that room over there. It's a
problem. And then I look at Mike and say,
Hey Mike,
get the rest of this hallway cleared.
So I'm actually handling two things,
but I give build a priority.
So that's a tweak. I'm
using assets. That's fine.
So sometimes yes,
you got to make these little adjustments.
Everyone's got a different
leadership style,
but you don't violate the
principles of leadership.